was that like the most pressure in your
career that sullivan was insane more
than even johnny carson because that was
a prime time sunday night show the world
was watching talk about make or break uh
talk about uh you know it was live so
everybody was you you did dress
rehearsal which was dead people and girl
scouts right so nobody laughed right so
they said well joan rivers is gonna do
seven and a half minutes tonight now you
get the nighttime audience and it goes
to 11 minutes well if you've gone longer
that means edie gourmet can sing he came
into my life because you just think i
came into yeah you've got to be dead and
ed could hold a grudge if you didn't do
a good job or you screwed someone else
over if you went to 11 minutes he would
have [ __ ] you good one time somebody
went short and they came back staged me
and it was all live right and they said
um
stretch and you know what i said to them
tell my husband
because edgar would have killed me if i
added material it was a great show it
was a great joke because you had to be
live you had no second chance when you
did the ed sullivan show did your career
tremendous change dramatically the next
day carson gave you new york la
the big cities
ed sullivan gave you america he put his
arm around you he has little joanie
rivers right the midwest said welcome
and he really you think he was you think
now that you think back on it he was
suffering from alzheimer's disease he
was at the end yeah it was very and she
was wonderful his wife she protected him
she watched him it's an amazing story ed
sullivan was like a gossip columnist who
got his own tv show he was horrible on
tv no personality good he was so stiff
yeah so out of it right you loved it you
love it and he and the show was a great
show as before everyone had their own
specials you saw everybody
you saw opera and then the dolly parton
came out and then joan rivers came out
see that's part of like america's got
america's got that's why i was just
gonna say i like doing america's got
town because it has all these varieties
that's what makes it interesting it's
fun it's fun and it's not the same thing
oh i lived for that ed sullivan joan
rivers and bell ringers you know yeah
almost fun
yeah and toppo gigio and all those cool
and then right after that richard burton
would come out and do something from
shakespeare would you send like sullivan
a gift after you appear like i mean you
probably felt so grateful to him i loved
him and he loved me and they would buy
you your clothes for the show wow and if
they liked you you got to keep them they
would walk upstairs and they would say
mr sullivan it was a whole thing would
like you to have your gown oh wow but
you never knew you took it off you hung
it up you put it in the closet
and then they would come and say mr
sullivan would like you to have your
gown how many times did you appear on
that follower 31 times 31 times made my
life that's an accolade i mean that's a
big deal i adored him you know because
he liked me i mean how many female
comics even got on at that point little
johnny rivers joni rivers who else you
got on there toady fields maybe tony was
before me out of 31 appearances did you
get to keep the gown every time or there
were times where he didn't kill you oh
he's got the guy always got the gown he
really liked me always got the gap
you